che sono precisamente come però fricka
ciao sono tornati oggi nuovo video ai
fax trucchetti più stupidi insidiato voi
questo video questo tipo di video 1 2 mi
affitto reagisci ai trucchetti dai fax
più stupidi che se sono su youtube o su
instagram
quindi grazie mille per averlo
consigliato ho cercato dei video ho
visto dei pezzi di video e fanno troppo
ridere
quindi lo vedono né di vederli assieme a
voi ho cambiato location tra un po
saprete il perché e volevo primo
aggiornarvi su una cosa tanto il
carichissimi su instagram
mi chiedete ogni giorno come stanno i
palloncini struttura vivi
allora eccoli qua sono ancora vivi più o
meno il giorno che stanno morendo però
considerando che siamo a maggio hanno
quasi due mesi infatti il 14 maggio
faranno i due mesi incredibile però
insomma dai questi sono i loro ultimi
giorni stavo per sono anche guidarli un
nome ma sapendo che sapendo che morirà
sul fra poco non voglio affezionarmi sì
comunque eccoli qua io li lasciano qua
dietro finché restano in b cast ora come
sempre mettetevi comodi pop corn e
patatine
fate un bel ex su questo video vediamo
quanti next riusciamo a raggiungere per
raggiungere i 10 mila
andrò a fare altri video divertenti
iniziamo subito
ok lexmark numero uno qui nei commenti
potrete votare qual è quello che vi ha
scioccato di più e qual è secondo voi il
più stupido conti alla fine portiamo
qual era il peggior e quindi perde
numero uno riguarda un telefono vediamo
un po osé banana sta tagliando la parte
della buccia della banana sopra
attenzione a quando fare station lo
stesso pre della banana funziona come un
dito potete scrollarsi basti dire tutto
non so perché qualcuno dovrebbe
utilizzare una banana al posto del suo
dito ma vabbè per le persone che non
hanno vita potrebbe essere una cosa
interessante uno per utilità di don 3
voi che voto gli date vediamo
quest'altro ammesso del roman soltanto
una soubrette a un cucchiaio per
mangiare e media
quel rahman
[Musica]
deliziosa spero che quella cosa non
finisca nel round se non sarebbe un
problema comunque l'arpac numero due
può essere utile ma io non mangiare mai
da insomma una forchetta attaccata con
la colla quindi di dare in due inutilità
numero 3
[Musica]
vediamo quanto è utile questo numero 3
ho messo un po di colla sta ritagliando
oddio sempre il telefono ah ok con i
bensì di colla stappando i buchi del
telefono non so se motivo sia per non
fare prendere polvere o perché nessuno
spiegato quindi numero 3 lido un 1
perché non capisco quale sia l'utilità
porta non far prendere polvere poi
immagino se devi fare incastrato non
reso più a togliere il pezzo di colla
oddio a tipo disegnato sullo schermo del
computer e ora sta votando grassatore
forse quello nello schermo penso che lo
rovini lo schermo non mai 24 gli do un 2
lo stesso forse funziona ma non
consiglio a nessuno di provarsi ok
numero 5 ma cinque nomi di far più 5
questo turchetto e se volete avere le
mani libere mentre tutte al bagno
situazione e mettete il tedesco non
essere militanti libero non ci ho mai
pensato che voto date queste
5 lido con una perché è molto molto
igienica molto il tetto numero 6
prendiamo questa faccenda
no vabbè ci ho messo sembrano due
telecomandi proseguito 1 perché non l'ho
proprio capito perché vorrebbe vedere la
scozia torre vabbè numero 7 ha di sé per
farvi piacere i broccoli mettete un po
di sprinkles sopra quelli che si mettono
sopra la torta ma gli do un 3 a questo
dai perché forse almeno mangiate un po
di brodo broccoli
ok quali numero 8 per applicare la crema
solare più seriamente usate come un
rullo no vabbè questo egli dovuto perché
funzionale troppo simpatico numero 99 su
che respiro bucato e precisamente
colorate in piedi così tutti vedrai che
avete perso il bucato questa geniale
questa insegnare questo merita un 10
poveri numero de sando tanti telecomandi
perché penso per non perderli po scomodo
notare numero 11 a questo l'avevo visto
fanno una cover dal palloncino novembre
però non puoi news fotocamera né
scaricarlo perchè tutto coperto quindi
si merita uno numero 11 fare un nuovo
con il ferro da stiro ok numero 12 sta
tagliando il betis perché per quale
motivo non capì il numero 3 vi si sta
delineando a forma delle scarpe
anche questo che sta che l'ho visto è in
pratica costruiti delle scarpe con la
colla a caldo utilissimo mero figure che
sono super resistenti caso l ok numero a
corde si difenda vediamo
[Musica]
sta mettendo un nuovo in guscio di nuovo
e scusate se interessi ma perché sempre
con i telefoni succedono queste cose
aspettiamo un corso ha sparato non me
l'aspettavo mettendo il guscio nel nella
parte del flash del telefono fa molta
più in pulce è abbastanza brutto da
vedere e da fare per occupazione ragazzi
di un veicolo che numero era questo e 14
penso quindi si merita un bel 7 perché
funziona anche se seri perché non lo
farei mai
ok prossimo quindici numero 15 al
tagliando questo non lo mettereste
l'apple sia zio spediamo a day 1a
scherzare limone devo dire che questo è
un po stupido però è divertente
penso che questo sia carino vediamo
adesso bene succo di limone e visite da
un tizio mouse perche mi ha sorpreso
best meta un bel tiro 8 qualche voto di
date aperto forse li sta facendo un po
meglio
sempre strani però forse questo vince
perché sta tagliando la partenza delle
frigo a.cal dando con la candela una
chiave cox sopra una chiave bruciata
copia della chiave sentiamo se ci
riuscirà riuscirà a creare una copia
della chiave ci si riesce
questo è un progetto generale vendiamo a
realizzare il tagliando vediamo sul
punta però
[Musica]
ragazzi a parte che non so perché ho
osato e cacciaviti funzionava per
funzionare dovete comunque avere la
chiave originale quindi non ha molto
senso forte per fare una coperta della
chiave però è quello ma ormai ho perso
il conto perché ne sono troppi di sly
fox così stupidi
vediamo questo per sempre la stessa
persona tra l'altro sta usando come
segnalibro del catch up ma perché non
ritrovare metto perché consumano
peggiori veramente ok sono molto curioso
di vedere questo e soprattutto perché
allora sto mettendo il telefono in un
sacchetto di plastica e sta scaldando il
coltello che ho provato anch'io se avete
visto i miei life ex tra che ti la
staffetta in questo non provato e
funziona davvero anche sono rimasto
molto sorpreso ma funziona
oltre a tagliarlo lo sigilla quindi però
non fate la casa perché veicolo
allora io non ho provato a mettere
l'acqua sopra ma non mi fiderei mai
allora prossimo se in cui mangiare lo
yogurt con la forchetta
purtroppo pensi ai belforte fatalismo
quindi invece di prendere un cucchiaino
effettivamente mettilo perché è ora
potrei mangiare la migliore stima che
quelle foto perché ragazzi per me vince
il treno mi ha fatto ridere
non capisco perché non dovremmo
riprendere un cucchiaino
ma se ne deve mettere lo spazio nato a
barchetta e questa è la fanta lunedì
prossimo
allora avevo fatto un assist a cena
fisso e fredda non lo mettere in forno
ma scalda la con infor perché stata casa
provate provare perché ne sicuramente si
è scaldata la fit ottimo e eroina
segnare lo stesso prossimo trucchetto
se non vi piacciono gli occhiali che
avete voler cambiare colore alle lenti
colorate con impennare voli
e evidente attori non evidenziatori
pennarelli indelebili le lenti e
rovinate lepers templi maggio su pc
trucchetti fantastici vediamo qua
abbiamo delle scarpe oddio cosa è cosa
troppo sesso fa mettendo uno di quei
quelli che si usano per le magliette per
i pochi condotte comprarlo qualcosa di
plastica per chiudere le scarpe perché
dovreste usare dei lacci tutti usano i
lacci e adesso meglio possa fare questi
cosiddetti di plastica che sono tipo
difficilissimi da togliere sicuramente
sono molto più comici pupazzo del
risultato bellissimo ma difficilmente
queste cose sono solo veloci vuole un
certo di fantasia stimo se avete lo
schermo che sembra che ci abbia fatto
qualcosa sopra un piccione
prendete uno slime vediamo come questo
spline super di liquido vediamo
per fare lo slime mette sullo schermo
non puliti allo schermo con un
fazzoletto ma ha usato lo slime
sicuramente funzionano molto meglio è
wow non l'hai pulito quel posto letto
sono piaciuti il quale vi ha scioccato
di più a me quello che mi ha fatto
ridere più di tutti è stato quello della
forchetta invece di prendere un campione
cucchiaino metterci in ascolto sono la
forchetta quello mi ha fatto ridere
tantissimo enti quale abbiamo cercato di
più quale vi ha fatto ridere più di
tutti così
eleggiamo un vincitore mi raccomando
lasciate un bel likes poter vedere altri
video divertenti e vi lascio ora qua 4
caselline potete scegliere se vedere i
miei live fax miei trucchetti tutti
magari potete giudicar li sa dirmi se
secondo voi anche m che si sono stupidi
e se cliccate pure qua per vedere i miei
trucchetti altri 20 mila su altre
challenge unboxing clive scegliete il
coratino su cui cliccare e buona visione